E aí
[Música]
eu nunca antes na história da humanidade
O número de pessoas morando em cidades
foi tão grande cerca de 54 por cento da
população mundial atualmente mora em
áreas Urbanas no Brasil essa taxa chega
próxima de 85 porcento e aqui no Estado
de São Paulo de onde eu tô falando 96
por centro de acordo com dados da ONU
todas as semanas três milhões de pessoas
saem do campo para vir morar nas cidades
isso Considerando o mundo inteiro
é só que historicamente esse processo de
urbanização de transformação solo Rural
pessoal Urbano para recebeu esse tanto
de pessoas e foi marcado por uma fase
chamada limpeza do terreno Ou seja a
remoção da vegetação da cobertura de
vegetação local
é daqui para que assim possam ser
construídas as edificações as casas os
prédios e para que sejam implantados os
sistemas de infraestrutura que dão
suporte para a vida nas cidades sistema
de abastecimento de água de distribuição
de energia de coleta de esgoto as vias
públicas mas tem um corpo de pesquisas
que é robusto e Crescente que têm
demonstrado a importância de uma outra
infraestrutura que tem sido deixado de
lado nesse planejamento Urbano essa
infraestrutura é a floresta Urbana que
consiste na somatória de todas as
árvores de uma cidade sejam elas em
áreas públicas ou privadas de espécie
exótica ou de espécie Nativa essa
infraestrutura Floresta Urbana tem um
grande potencial de melhorar a nossa
vida nas cidades
e elas podem influenciar mitigando
enchentes problemas de enchentes e
alagamentos diminuindo a temperatura das
cidades e reduzindo o consumo de energia
melhorando a qualidade do ar e tem uma
linha de pesquisa que tem se dedicado
recentemente a relacionar os benefícios
da saúde com a presença de árvores nas
cidades também tem um corpo de estudos
que têm demonstrado que a presença de
árvores nos centros urbanos diminui as
nossas taxas de estresse diminui a
probabilidade de crianças que moram
perto de áreas verdes frequentam áreas
verdes desenvolverem transtornos mentais
na fase adulta ou até relacionando o
consumo de álcool cerveja e outras
substâncias a devido à presença de áreas
verdes Porque como o stress é menor para
que pessoas que frequentam áreas verdes
o consumo dessas substâncias também
em um recente estudo britânico
demonstrou que para cada uma libra
investida na expansão e na qualificação
de áreas verdes 6 libras são
economizados no sistema de saúde por mês
apesar de todos esses esse conhecimento
de todos os benefícios que as árvores e
as áreas verdes proporcionam no ambiente
Urbano a realidade das cidades
brasileiras deixam muito a desejar de
maneira geral as cidades brasileiras
apresentam baixa quantidade de árvores
quando a gente insere a variável social
a questão fica pior ainda existe um
padrão entre na cidade de brasileiras
que também não é só de cidades
brasileiras cidades ao redor do mundo
apresenta o mesmo padrão bairros com
predominantes de predominância de
pessoas pretas negras pardas e de baixa
renda apresentam menores taxas de
vegetação e de árvores urbanas Ou seja a
vegetação Urbana tem
o Sepe influencia um acesso essas áreas
verdes
um hobby McDonald's que é um importante
cientista de uma organização
internacional que pesquisa Conservação
da natureza um relatório publicado esse
ano afirmou que por muito tempo a gente
tem entendido considerado as árvores e
as áreas verdes como item de luxo eu
queria que aproveitar para aprofundar
essa reflexão do Hobby mais do que um
item de luxo a gente tenha entendido por
muitas vezes as árvores como privilégio
de poucos e aqui que a gente tem que
mudar esse paradigma as árvores não
podem ser um privilégio de todos Elas
têm que ser entendido como um serviço de
utilidade pública uma infraestrutura que
todos têm acesso mas o que isso as
árvores e as áreas verdes têm que ser
entendida como um direito de todos o
direito à floresta Urbana bom eu
trabalho pesquisa com Floresta Urbana há
mais de 10 anos
Oi e esse ano a cidade onde eu trabalho
foi reconhecido em um programa
internacional da ONU sobre gestão de
arborização Urbana a partir desse
resultado eu fui convidado para fazer
parte de um time que está elaborando a
política nacional de arborização Urbana
objetivo dessa política elaborar e
fornecer instrumentos e subsídios para
que todas as cidades do Brasil possa
elaborar os seus planos diretores
aumentar a sua cobertura arbórea e
reduzir a desigualdade na distribuição
da vegetação Até lá a gente tem um longo
caminho a ser percorrido e eu queria
trazer aqui algumas estratégias que a
gente pode adotar para caminhar
paralelamente esse processo e tentar
melhorar a condição das nossas cidades e
a nossa qualidade de vida nelas
e com essas estratégias Elas têm
dimensões diferentes a primeira delas
consiste em a gente olhar o nosso
entorno a gente começar a pesquisar
pessoas e coletivos que Já realizam esse
serviço e essa prática de plantar
árvores em áreas públicas os coletivos
de Plantadores de árvores como por
exemplo no Rio de Janeiro tem usar
bonitas urbanos na cidade de Campinas
tem um movimento resgate do Cambuí
interior de São Paulo também no interior
de São Paulo em Ribeirão Preto tem um
movimento está com calor plante árvores
ou às vezes ações de pessoas que já
plantam árvores nas áreas verdes ou
associações de moradores como seu Hélio
em São Paulo que tem um link histórico e
pronto mais de 25 mil árvores dando
condições para que o primeiro Parque
Linear da cidade fosse implantado
E essas pessoas elas prestam um grande
serviço para a sociedade e é importante
que a gente soma esforços a elas a gente
procure cada vez mais conhecimento do
local e das espécies que nós vamos
plantar aqui também isso não vem essa é
um problema no futuro a segunda
estratégia ela tá mais relacionada no
campo da democracia e da participação
social e consiste em a gente se apropria
dos espaços de decisão pública nos
conselhos de Meio Ambiente municipais
das câmaras de vereadores e a gente
faltar os políticos os representantes
legais para que essas demandas sobre as
cidades mais arborizadas cidades mais
verdes 16 cidades mais saudáveis sejam
pautas e conta com recursos um
cronograma E que sejam realizados os
projetos
e ainda nessa linha uma última
estratégia seria no campo eleitoral a
cada dois anos Nós escolhemos nossos
representantes locais e depois estadual
e Federal e que a gente passa olhar com
carinho para que se esses representantes
estão incluindo essas pautas os seus
projetos os seus planos de governo
pertence a gente quer atingir os
objetivos do desenvolvimento sustentável
até 2030 do qual o Brasil foi signatário
a gente precisa começar a plantar essas
árvores agora muito obrigado